last week Shane Gillis made his third
career appearance on the flagrant
podcast with Andrew Schultz for possibly
their best episode together yet there
was also a big firsttime collaboration
in the podcast World last week as Tom
sagora made his debut appearance on the
take your shoes off podcast with Rick
Glassman you like to wear cans okay I do
it for Logistics so no no no I I like to
check are we peeking how's the volume
how's it going you know okay and then
sometimes if we call people it's always
exciting to see any new firsttime
podcast matchups even though guys with
established history can often be just as
entertaining for example